hi everyone my name is Johan uh you can
find me as at J herland online I am a
developer productivity engineer at twg
twg is the open source facing part of
the modus create software consultancy at
twg we use and Produce open source
software to help our clients solve hard
problems more on that
later so there is an elephant in the
scientific community room today known as
the replication crisis a lot of
scientific results are being published
but then other scientists struggle to
reproduce the same results the basics of
science itself are based on being able
to reproduce experiments so this is kind
of fundamental to science itself if it
cannot be reproduced then it isn't
really
science data science has a particular
responsibility here not only is it a
huge discipline in its own right but it
has also become a vital component in
many other scientific disciplines and
python being such an important tool in
data science is of course also affected
by this I I'm happy to see that
reproducibility in Python and Jupiter
notebooks is already such a popular
topic here just yesterday I'll listen to
n Baraza talk about how to improve
reproducibility in notebooks and later
Eric levenson talked about how to make
ml experiments more
reproducible but uh let's start here by
looking at the status quo I want to
highlight two recently published papers
that have looked at reproducibility and
python
specifically first we have this paper
from four months ago that looked at
reproducibility of Jupiter notebooks in
the Life Sciences these researchers
collected a large amount of notebooks
via papers available on PubMed
Central they then automated a process to
copy these notebooks and attempt to
reproduce the results I'm going to jump
straight to the numbers they found
spoiler alert the numbers are not very
good so here's from the abstract out of
more than 22,000 python notebooks all
almost 16,000 or 70% declared any
dependencies at all around 10,000 or 46%
had dependencies that could be installed
and around 1,00 or 5.3% could be run
without errors and only 879 or 3.9%
could actually reproduce the results in
the
end Let's uh take a closer look at the
notebooks that were run but then failed
with an error this corresponds to to the
yellow bar but but we want to subtract
those that ran without errors the most
commonly raised error by far is module
not found error and in position number
three we find the more General import
error both of these are closely related
to missing dependencies and uh together
these two errors were raised by 29% of
the total number of python
notebooks in other words if we overlay
these numbers and we focus on the
failures at each stage we find that 30%
% of notebooks failed to declare any
dependencies at all for another 24% of
them the declared dependencies fail to
install and even then for another 29%
there are errors while trying to import
dependencies so when we look at
everything together more than 80% of
notebooks fail to reproduce due to
missing or incorrect dependency
declarations let's move on to the second
study this paper is just a couple of
months old and looks at the pipi
ecosystem a very Central part of our
python
Community these authors start from the
10,000 most popular libraries on Pipi
narrowing it down to 8,282 libraries
that have more than two releases they
then attempt to install each and every
release of these libraries to find
issues in the project
configuration these issues could be
related to dependency declarations or
other problems that become apparent when
you try to install or use a library from
Pipi I'm going to shortcut to the most
relevant numbers here
they find that only 65% of Pipi
libraries can be successfully installed
and imported into your code around 5%
fail to install for various other
reasons so around 30% can be installed
but may encounter errors as soon as you
import them depending on exactly which
parts you import or what your runtime
environment looks
like digging a bit into how they
categorize the various failures we can
see that the vast majority of failures
are again due to missing or incorrect
dependency declaration
so both these Pap both of these papers
show that missing or incorrect uh
dependency declarations is a significant
and important problem in the python
world but what do I really mean when I
talk about missing or incorrect
dependency
declarations let's quickly recap the
basics of dependencies and dependency
declarations in Python this should be
familiar to anybody who has worked with
python for a while so I import some
thirdparty Library like numpy in my
python code when python runs this code
it will look in my runtime environment
for the numpy
library this is the dependency in order
for my code to work numpy has to be
installed but of course I have installed
npy so this is no longer a problem
right well what happens when you check
out my code onto your machine and try to
run it it fails because you haven't
installed
numpy this is the works on my machine
problem the code we run is the same but
the runtime environment is different and
because of those differences it works on
my machine but not on yours the real
problem here is that I failed to declare
my dependency on npy now there are many
different ways to declare dependencies
in the python ecosystem I could have
written a Pi Project tummel or a
setup.py to configure my project setup.
CFG is another alternative and we could
even discuss whether dependencies should
be declared Loosely or pinned to a
specific version unfortunately I cannot
go into all of those details in this
talk so instead I'll just go for the
simplest declaration here the bare
minimum that any tool would need to be
able to discover our dependency and help
our users resolve it this requirements
txt file declares that we expect to have
numpy available when we run this project
it is a declaration of our numpy
dependency let's import another
module we add an import of pandas to our
code this is a new dependency but we
haven't yet declared it unsurprisingly
we call this an Undeclared
dependency we can have the opposite
problem as well let's say that we
experimented with tensor flow at some
point in our code and we did the right
thing by declaring it in our
requirements dxt then later we ended up
not using it after all but we forgot to
remove it from our dependency
declaration we call this an unused
dependency unused dependencies don't
directly affect the reproducibility of
our Pro of our project uh and they are
therefore not as critical as on declared
dependencies we still want to avoid them
though tensor flow for example is
several hundred megabytes and this can
end up wasting space and time for our
users so to summarize on the left hand
side we have our real dependencies the
set of packages that we actually depend
on in our python code and on the right
we have our declared dependencies the
set of packages that we have listed as
required either in our project
configuration or in something like a
requirement
cxt we can combine these two sets in a
vend diagram where the dependencies we
use but don't declare end up on the left
these are our Undeclared dependencies
these make it hard or impossible to use
and ultimately reproduce our project
conversely the dependencies we declare
but don't use end up on the right these
are our unused dependencies and they add
unnecessary bloat to our
project obviously we want for all our
dependencies to end up in the center we
want to properly declare the
dependencies we actually use and only
those now at twe we help clients across
many Industries to solve hard problems
and we often encounter projects with or
without python that struggle with
reproducibility in one way or
another a little over a year ago my
colleague n who works in the data
Engineering Group at twg found herself
repeatedly helping projects that
suffered from Undeclared dependencies
and she wanted to automate the kind of
dependency analysis that we just did in
the previous
slides Maria also from our data
Engineering Group joined her a and a
little bit later I also joined I am not
the data engineer I am part of another
twe group called skill able builds but
even if I usually don't work on the same
kinds of projects and clients as our
data Engineers I still often see the
same kinds of issues with respect to
lack of reproducibility and the works on
my machine
problem along the way we had another
colleague Vince join us for a little
while before he had to move on and
finally Jian joined us as well almost
half a year ago
now together we have created F TOS a
tool for finding Undeclared and unused
dependencies in Python
projects and today we are for Co coers
that work on fault adeps in between our
client
engagements the point of fault adeps is
to do exactly the kind of analysis that
we just walked through when you run
fault adeps on your project fault adeps
will find the set of packages you import
in your code and compare it to your
declared dependencies it then produces a
report showing you any Undeclared or
unused
dependencies you can consider fault
adeps as a linter not a regular linter
for your code but rather a lter for your
dependencies
here we see faulted apps being run
without any options in our little toy
project the output first lists the
Undeclared dependencies that FEPS found
in this case pandas and Below we see the
unused dependencies that was found in
this case tensorflow if you run fa adeps
in a large project you can ask for a
more detailed report and this will also
tell you the file and line number where
each Undeclared or unused dependency was
found here we see that pandas the pandas
import happens in code. py online to and
we see that the tensorflow unus
dependency is declared in requirements
of
txt so where can you use FEPS we support
python code both in dopy scripts and in
jupyter notebooks we support any version
of python that is not ancient and for
now we run on Linux and Mac OS but
Windows support is already in the
works for dependency declarations we
support the most common formats used in
the python ecosystem today setup.py is
complicated as it can contain
arbitrarily complex pyth statements but
we are able to parse out the declared
dependencies in most
cases to use fa adeps you can either
install it into your project developer
environment or you can for example use
pipex to make it generally
available I also want to emphasize the
configurability of faulted deps you can
configure everything on the command line
but also via the environment or via a
tool. faep section in P project
ATL everything is documented in The Help
option or in the project reading
and finally we also have a nice command
line option to quickly create the tool.
faep section based on the current
options let's have a look at some more
output
options we want to make FEPS as
transparent and helpful as possible so
that you can understand how and why
something ends up in the
report you can run faulted deps with
list sources to see the files where
fault adeps are looking for your actual
and decare dependencies this is often
the first step in debugging fa is it
actually looking at it in the right
place next you can run it with list
Imports to see which Imports it finds in
your code and you can run it with list
steps to see which dependencies it finds
to have been declared finally if you
want to write some code to interact with
the analysis that faulted UPS does you
can use the Json option uh this will
give you machine readable output with
all the Gory
details now let's move on to deploying
fault depths into your project
workflow running faulted depths on your
project once in a while is obviously a
good idea but there is extra value if
you can have it run automatically
whenever you make changes the pre-commit
tool instruments the promit hooking git
and it is great for when you need to
automatic when you need automatic checks
to run on every commit in your git
repository so let's set up faulted UPS
to run as a pre-commit
hook assuming that we are not already
using the pre-commit tool we need to
install that first the documentation on
pre-commit tocom list a few different
ways but we'll do a simple pip install
pre-commit here next we need to tell
pre-commit how to run fault ad
apps we create this pre-commit
config.yml
file and we add these lines to it these
lines tell pre-commit where to find
fault adeps which version to use and
which parts of f adeps to run we want to
find both Undeclared and unused
dependencies in the code we're trying to
commit here don't worry about
remembering these lines you'll find them
at the bottom of the fs readme either on
our GitHub page or pii page
next we uh we activate the pre-commit uh
by running pre-commit install pre-commit
is now armed and ready to run on every
commit we do so let's test it
out we add an import Panda statement to
our code and then we try to commit it
pre-commit fails and prevents us from
committing this Undeclared dependency in
addition to the failure message from
pre-commit itself we also get the fa
fault adeps output pointing to which
dependency is Undeclared and where it
was imported let's fix this by declaring
the pandas dependency
properly so we add pandas to our
requirements txt and then we retry the
commit and now pre-commit succeeds and
our commit is
done finally let's illustrate pre-commit
catching an unused dependency so let's
add tensor flow to our requirements txt
but without actually using tensor flow
anywhere now when we try to commit
pre-commit fails again but this time it
is the unused check that triggers and
fault adeps tells us which dependency is
unused and where it was
declared another way to make sure fault
adeps runs regularly and quickly catches
problems with your dependencies is to
run it as a check in your CI system I
will quickly show a guub actions setup
for fault adeps here if you use a
different CI system the setup should
follow similar steps but the syntax may
be different so we set up a GitHub
action by writing this file into our
repository I'm not going to spend too
much time on the syntax here it should
look familiar to anyone who has already
set up a GitHub actions for a python
project but uh quickly we spend a few
lines declaring what platform and python
version we're using and getting
everything ready then we do the usual
thing to install the project
dependencies here we make sure that pip
is up to date and then we install
everything from our requirements txt and
finally comes the Fault adeps part we
install fault adeps with Pip and then we
simply run fault adeps with a detailed
option if you have configured faeds in
your P project toml that configuration
will of course also be picked up and
used by fault
adeps once this is committed to your
project GitHub will automatically run
fault to depths on new commits and pull
requests so let's see what this looks
like when we actually create a pull
request that adds an Undeclared
dependency here is a pull request that
adds our old friend pandas as an
Undeclared
dependency once the GitHub action has
run we get an indication on the pull
request overview that FEPS the FEPS
check is failing and if we go into the
details of the fail check we can see
that the output of fed deps is pointing
us to the problematic pandas
import now the toy sample we've used so
far has helped show the basic concepts
but things are always more complex in
the real world let's draw the rest of
the damn owl first we will look at a
part of the dependency analysis that
we've glossed over so far but that is
crucial to in order to produce prod
correct results this is one of the cases
where we believe fault adeps goes the
extra mile especially compared to doing
dependency analysis by
hand and that is how to match import
names and package names in Python it
sounds simple so far we've imported
numpy in our python code and we've
declared the numpy package as our
dependency numpy happens to use the same
name for the package and the import but
python is not strict about this the
package name you declare as a dependency
does not always match the name you need
to import in your code psyit learn for
example um is is a popular example here
uh the package that in that you install
or declare as a dependency is called
psychic learn but the name that you
import in your code is SK
learn there are also cases where a
single package provides multiple import
names like the setup tools package for
example it has long provided both the
setup tools import name as well as the
PKG resources import name in order to
import either of those modules you need
to have setup tools install
sold there are even more complex cases
as well which I won't get into here but
it should already be clear that we need
some kind of mapping between the import
names and the package names and without
a good mapping we won't be able to
correctly match import names to declare
dependencies and we'll end up reporting
Undeclared uh and unused dependencies
incorrectly fortunately we can usually
build a good mapping using your
Project's python environment now we
don't really know how or where install
your project dependencies it could be a
virtual en somewhere or you could depend
on a systemwide installation or
something
else however let's assume that your
project dependencies have been installed
somewhere and when your project is
running python is able to find those
packages and successfully import the
modules as long as fault adeps can find
this environment where the dependencies
are installed then it can build a
correct
mapping so naturally we put a lot of
effort into finding the right python
environments so that the analysis will
be as correct as
possible first fault adeps looks for the
environments that are associated
directly with the project without any
configuration we will search under the
current directory for any environments
located inside your project any projects
uh many projects use a virtual en inside
the project itself and these will be
found
here you can also uh pass one or more
paths directly to fault adeps and this
will limit the search space this is
often useful in a monor repo setting
where your repository can contain a lot
of different python
projects you can also use the panv
option to directly Point fault adeps at
your Project's
environment in addition to looking
inside the project we will also always
consider the python environment in which
fault adeps itself is installed thus if
you install fault adeps into the same
environment where your project
dependencies are installed you will
always get good results together these
two approaches give good results as long
as the dependencies are installed on
your machine but there might be
situations where the dependencies are
not installed or not yet installed how
do we deal with
these so uh first sort of smallest side
here for really Advanced users we have a
way to provide a custom mapping where
you can tell fed apps directly how
packages names and import names
correspond um this is usually not used
we don't expect most users to to to use
this but uh when it is there it takes
precedence over everything else
otherwise we also have an option called
install deps this will set up a
temporary virtual EnV and install the
missing dependencies from pii just so
that faults can get the correct mapping
obviously this is quite an expensive
option and not always suitable so it's
not enabled by default and then when all
other things fail we fall back to
something that we call the identity
mapping this is a very simple assumption
that package names are synonymous with
import names when we find a package name
that we simply cannot resolve any other
way we will match it against an import
of the same name although this
assumption often works out it is um it
is also sometimes Incorrect and that's
why we only use it as a final
Resort so let's demonstrate how this
works in practice with psychic learn
remember we declare a dependency on
Psychic learn in requirements dxt but
what we actually import is called SK
learn and the goal here is for fault
adeps to figure out that these two names
are indeed related otherwise it would
report escaler learn as an Undeclared
dependency and pyit learn as an unused
dependency so here's how F to deps
figures this
out we take the dependency name Psy it
learn and pass it to the first stage of
our dependency resolver this is the
custom mapping as I said on the previous
slide this takes precedence over
anything else but also this mapping is
usually not provided so I'll skip pause
it for
now next we look at python environments
associated with the project if we can
find an environment where psyit learn is
installed
then we will see that SK learn is indeed
provided by this package and our match
has been made otherwise we will move on
to the next to look at the environment
where fault to deps is installed the
same procedure here if it finds psyit
learn then we're done otherwise we are
starting to run out of options so at
this point if install deps is enabled we
will create the temporary virtual en and
pip install pyic learn into that and
that will also tell us that psychic
learn and SK learn are associated and
finally Resort if install deps was not
enabled that would be the identity
mapping this would actually do the wrong
thing in this case as it would assume
that the psyit learn package provides
the same import names pyit learn since
this doesn't match reality and also
doesn't match what's in our code fault
adeps would incorrectly uh report SK
learn as Undeclared and psyit learn as
unused as you can see we try very hard
to find the correct mapping before it
comes to
this I'll quickly go over some more
complex ities that we've come across
with FEPS so far this should give you an
impression of where FEPS is currently at
and where we still have some ways to go
the first one has to do with packages
that faulted apps would often report as
unused because some dependencies are
never actually meant to be imported at
all this goes for tools in your
development environment like formatters
and lters or even FEPS itself it applies
to typ stops packages and sometimes also
other packages that are part of some
bigger framework where the actual
framework takes care of importing the
package for you fault adeps has code to
recognize and handle the first two
categories but the last one is still
incomplete so we therefore provide an
ignore unused option that allows you to
override the unused analysis for a given
package next python is a very Dynamic
language and you can often work run
missing dependencies or Alternatives in
the actual code itself either by
conditionally importing a module or by
providing an alternative import when the
first import fails fault adeps currently
considers All Imports as if they are
unconditional meaning that we will want
all of them to be declared but as above
when you know better than fault adeps
you can use the ignore Undeclared option
here Dynamic Imports is another thing
that is hard to analyze sometimes it is
actually impossible to know what module
will be imported without actually
running your code these cases are
currently skipped by fault adeps but
we're looking into how we can improve
the situation and
finally there are ways to declare
different categories of dependencies in
Python depending on your context some of
these should considered optional by
fault adeps we have plans to add support
for this but for now fault adeps will
treat all declared dependencies as hard
dependencies and with that let's
summarize reproducibility matters in
science generally but also python
specifically a major hurdle to
reproducibility in python is missing or
incorrect dependency
declarations faulted deps helps you fix
this by highlighting Undeclared and
unused dependencies in your project
fault adeps works with python scripts
and jupyter notebooks across most
popular python versions and platforms fa
adeps understands the various ways in
which projects declared python
dependencies fault ad apps should work
out of the box on your project and if it
doesn't it's easily configurable and
finally we hope you will make fault
adeps an automated part of your workflow
so that your projects can avoid the
works on my machine
problem and that's it for for me really
thank you for listening and go check out
fa adeps we are on GitHub and PPI of
course and we recently started a Discord
where we will help you with any
questions you might have about fubs we
also occasionally write on The Tweak
blog and there you can also read about
all the other things that twers are up
to as I mentioned earlier we have a data
Engineering Group at twg ready to help
you build and scale your data pipelines
or tackle any data engineering problems
that you face my colleague n has also
started a generative AI group at twg we
will help you create custom llm and NLP
applications with a focus on private AI
open Source large language models and
datadriven evaluation and with that I'm
happy to take questions either now or
you can find me afterwards uh I'm at
jurand on GitHub mad on social LinkedIn
and elsewhere